so well we've just seen a fully
populated data Hall which we've reached
capacity within and we never take you to
what we call phase two dateable 3 which
is the most recent capacity that we
brought to the market really to
facilitate the large demand that we're
seeing from the researchers and the
higher education institutions it's kind
of after and before isn't it ok
assuming we can get in so this building
was built three years ago and the
building shell was built three years ago
it was designed from the ground up as a
data center most data centers are
converted buildings of some description
predominately where and distribution
warehouses so a lot of thought went into
just the simple building fabric to make
it simpler more cost-effective and
easier to operate in life support
stories where the fire suppression
system resides so there's an if there's
a fire within the building the system in
the each of the data pools can figure
out exactly where that fire is and
provide directly the fire suppression to
it to make sure that we put the fire out
this is very responsible so this is the
second phase of capacity that we're
bringing on live within the facility
it delivers two thousand five hundred
kilowatts of IT load and what we've just
shown you is a fully populated
operational data hall with all the racks
and the IT infrastructure running in
anger within it this is just about to
have the first item of structure
installed within it and that will be
going live in the next six to eight
weeks the space the power the
connectivity yeah yeah so we are simply
the facilitator of the building the
infrastructure that supports it all the
resilience that they require to make
sure they're comfortable they're there I
t's housing the right place in the right
location that it's always on and we are
the kind of the base layer for the
foundation if you like of the IT stack
in that regard so how many customers
in a date or this side we would look to
get between 20 and 30 higher education
research customers within this sort of
space of capacity doing there'll be a
loss of high-performance computing in
here but we will see more and more
standard applications and standard IC
footprint coming within this space yeah
where email web access and the way we
put that into context is you'll have a
standard enterprise rack of computing
wall really supported by four kilowatts
of electricity a high performance
computing rack could be supported by up
to 30 kilowatts of electricity and
that's the difference that's there they
can be very different in the amount of
variety hardware that's within it and is
the power of the supporter in the past
these are institutions are trying to go
and procure these services directly in
the market themselves in effect what's
happened is janeth genic straight
jessica brought them together and
consolidated their requirements and we
treat them as a single customer even
though there are many customers that sit
underneath the JISC agenda framework and
in doing so we can therefore offer a
wholesale type price the pod that we
were standing in previously would be
costing them probably thirty thousand
pounds a month or something like that
depending upon the IT load within it if
you look at the analysis that Jessica
and Jennifer done they reckon that they
are the customers are saving up to two
thirds of their cost from trying to
provision it themselves put it in within
their own campus estates or trying to go
to market directly without having the
framework around them so the cost is
cost savings are significant so
obviously we're all now no no he's not
here how long before this is a heathen
web computing well the space we were
just in we filled within eight months
and at the beginning of the framework
it's a wizard that the Quietus piece of
time period of time if you like so I
will forecast this will be filled in the
next six months and because of our
confidence in that we've already started
phase three which delivers a similar
amount of capacity in space that's just
behind you for your finger onto the
finger vein reader
it's part of the cloud
we're not the cloud it's part of the
cloud and what are we are we don't have
an ambition to be a cloud provider our
ambition is simply to enable the cloud